visiblement on va devoir rester dans cet
espace tant qu'on sera sur scène ça ira
on a intérêt si on veut leur parler de
consommation des espaces
alors comme vous vous en doutez muayad
rien on est de la génération y et notre
génération était mieux que n'importe
quel autre génération ce que c'est que
de consommer pourquoi parce qu'on n'a
jamais autant consommé
c'est simple tout à portée d'un
mouvement de doigt un clic un swipe et
cet accès à l'illimité
il paraît complètement banal aujourd'hui
clairement on a des comportements qui
sont aux antipodes de ce qu'on devrait
faire pour préserver nos ressources mais
aussi pour nous préserver nous mêmes de
toutes les ressources
il y en a une que nous consommons tous
sans même nous en rendre compte que ce
soit pour l'occuper physiquement ou pour
nos besoins
c'est l'espace on ne peut pas continuer
à rêver d'une consommation individuelle
illimité sur une planète qui n'est pas
en extension un chiffre 500 millions lui
500 millions les sommes auraient
suffisamment d espace pour vivre cultivé
et habiter en harmonie avec la nature
lui mais allez vous nous dire avec 7,5
milliards d'êtres humains nous sommes
loin du compte
nous vous répondrons alors oui mais avec
10 milliards en 2050 et 15 milliards en
nous serons encore plus loin du compte
mais ne nous alarme ou pas sur des
problèmes démographiques agissons plus
tôt chacun de nous sur des éléments que
l'on peut maîtriser pour nous la
consommation de l'espace en est un alors
ce qui est essentiel c'est d'éviter de
consommer de l'espace inutilement rendez
vous compte au moment où je vous parle à
chaque seconde qui passe est un bout de
forêt de l'équivalent d'un terrain de
football qui disparaissent à peu près 1
hectare donc maîtrisons au moins
l'étalement des villes c'est capital
pour préserver nos ressources
en fait il faudrait qu'une conscience
globale elle émerge et pour ça il faut y
réfléchir à plusieurs
alors par exemple moi et adrien on y
réfléchit à deux parce que
l'architecturé déjà elle se fait jamais
seul
depuis elle a de sens que dans les
changes et le partage et nous ce qu'on
aimerait partager avec vous ce soir
l'optimisation des usages de l'espace
alors qu'est ce que c'est comment
fait-on avril va vous en dire un peu
plus rassurez vous la solution est plus
simple que vous ne le pensez elle réside
dans le vide
et oui il suffit de regarder tout autour
de vous pour constater que tout est fait
de ville dans nos villes dans nos
maisons
ces résidus des espaces peuvent être de
taille différente peut s'agir d'un
tercis entre deux bâtiments des friches
mais aussi de grenier des toitures
d'escalier oui tous ces espaces
délaissés sont des orphelins
alors que la population a des besoins
croissante c'est d'un fou de les
identifier
et c'est à nous de les magnifier
ajoutons adrien quand même que c'est
vide ils sont nécessaires parce que ils
vont donner une âme à une ville et c'est
aussi eux qui vont y participer
d'ailleurs même levitte qui sont
délaissés ils vont pouvoir abriter des
événements inattendus et souvent ils
sont aussi support d'art alors ça peut
être tout simplement des graffiti sur le
mur des installations éphémères ou
encore des sculptures urbaines et ce qui
est intéressant c'est que en plus de ça
ils sont ils peuvent laisser de la
végétation la place pour la végétation
en ville tout simplement
et pourquoi par exemple quand tu as une
ancienne voie de chemin de fer ne
peut-on pas l'utiliser pour l'imaginer
comme une balade urbaine qui déambulent
dans la ville comme la high line de new
york par exemple ou plus modestement la
ceinture la petite ceinture de paris et
pourquoi quand on a un ancien bâtiment
industriel
on ne pourrait pas en faire je ne sais
pas une serre alors ça paraît simple ce
que je dis en fait il faut aborder ces
espaces en leur donnant une seconde vie
et en réfléchissant sur leur nouvelle
identité
au delà des usages habituels aujourd'hui
l'idée ce n'est pas de vous proposer
d'habiter sur une bretelle d'autoroute
ou que belfort ressemble à manhattan
demain vous savez optimiser l'espace
ce n'est pas forcément densifier mais
c'est avant tout savoir intégrer
ponson airs pensions notre spécialité en
fonction de nos besoins et de
l'environnement
l' architecture n'existe pas dans le
contexte qui la con
réfléchissons intelligemment alors par
exemple moi j'ai une anecdote assez
drôle tu es à paris c'était une annonce
qui circulait ya quelques années où
c'était un propriétaire qui proposait un
cellier de trois mètres carrés avec
vasistas com au prix de 50 mille euros
alors cette annonce pour la justifier il
avait quand même indiqué que ça se
situait près de l'île saint louis alors
cette annonce qui est hallucinante elle
nous rappelle quand même qu'il ya des
pressions foncières qui sont très forts
dans de nombreuses villes et pour lutter
contre ça nous proposons une
architecture qui est économique
il consomme peu d'énergie et pour
laquelle chaque mètre carré est
important mais pas n'importe lesquels
n'ont plus le cellier trois mètres
carrés il aurait été intéressant s'il
avait été atteint dans un appartement et
qu'on aurait pu l'utiliser comme surface
supplémentaire
il faut se rendre compte que la petite
surface c'est devenu un marché à part
entière et ça s'explique aussi de
manière sociologique mais les familles
qui ont tendance à quitter les villes on
a les jeunes qui ont tendance à habiter
de plus en plus longtemps chez leurs
parents parce que mine de rien un petit
appartement à loyer abordable c'est
difficile à trouver et les célibataires
ils sont également dans ce cas là et ils
sont d'ailleurs de plus en plus nombreux
donc les nouvelles générations en fait
elle s'affirme dans la dématérialisation
et en plus de ça elles sont elle préfère
l'expérience le social et la location
donc pour nous construire dans le détail
ça va être beaucoup plus important que
la taille du logement soit en france
l'idée selon laquelle tous les mètres
carrés peuvent être utilisés est encore
marginale ce n'est pas forcément le cas
au japon afin de conserver des espaces
de vie qualitatif l'architecturé
japonaise s'appuie sur des notions
telles que l'intégration divine
l'intelligence de la forme la matière la
simplicité
l'ergonomie c'est sur ces principes que
nous bâtissons notre langage
alors oui forcément celle des rites
l'héritage d'un art de vivre
mais toutes ces préoccupations tous ces
modes de pensée ces valeurs peuvent nous
est commune
dans une problématique qui devient
mondiale illustrons nos propos prenons
l'exemple d'un hôtel bien indien que
notre dernière nuit fut très agréable
est il forcément nécessaire d'avoir une
chambre de 20 mètres carrés quand quatre
mètres carrés suffisent à dormir et même
à plusieurs afin de conserver et de
respecter cette consommation des espaces
les hôtels capsules hôtel typiquement
japonais propose des chambres constitué
d'une simple cabine lit de deux mètres
carrés alors oui ces espaces la nature
et la manière de les vifs sont
complètement différente de la nôtre mais
ils ont le mérite de rester neutre
rapport à leur spécialité
thibault et moi une croyons comme toutes
questions environnementales c'est à
travers un nouveau langage et de
nouvelles habitudes que l' architecture
saura répondre aux besoins de demain
alors au début on vous a montré l'espace
dans lequel on doit se tenir pour parler
devant vous six mois ou adrien on se
sentait à l'étroit
une solution serait de faire un autre
espace un peu plus loin et cette
solution c'est justement celle que l'on
veut éviter
pourquoi parce que en plus de consommer
deux fois plus d espace il faudrait
créer une circulation entre les deux
pour que l'on puisse communiquer
ensemble et cette circulation là ça va
être une perte complètement inutiles
pour l'environnement alors pourquoi est
ce qu'on vous dit tout ça ce soir c'est
parce que notre but c'est aussi tout
simplement de vous sensibiliser
concrètement prenions conscience du
potentiel qui nous entoure
recyclons au même titre que n'importe
quel d'henri l'espace un dernier exemple
ce n'est pas parce qu'une famille
s'agrandit qu'elle doit obligatoirement
changer de logement des aménagements
astucieux ou une simple extension
peuvent faire la faire un logement doit
offrir plus d espace que de surface
alors pensé et repensé la spatialité
pour préserver respecter et magnifié
nous et notre planète en avons besoin
chacun dans son quotidien peut
influencer de manière positive pour
l'évolution environnementale pour les
prochaines décennies et notre profession
elle a le devoir de réponse
à ces questions à travers un nouveau
langage donc les outils ils existent ils
sont là donc tout simplement
utilisons-les cet espace sera maintenant
le vôtre cet espace dont vous n'avez
jamais su quoi faire repenser le nous
avons confiance
[Applaudissements]